on the day of this year's Golden Globes
you posted a picture that blew people's
minds I don't know if you remember doing
this it's a picture of you but pad well
that's what it is
it's first of all nothing I have nothing
against this patient these pictures
fantastic but I'm curious I didn't I'm
not aware of the whole buttpad
phenomenon can you tell me about that
well look I guess not a lot of people
know about it which is why I posted it
because you know when you're getting
ready and particularly if you're a girl
maybe if you're a guy you want to feel
like you fit into your dress and you
you're your best self and people wear
bras and they've also invented these
things called buff pads which will just
get for me I like cupcakes
I like big juicy buns you want to you
want to yeah on to other people on me I
just love them I think buns are great
and you and I was wearing a tighter
dress and I was like oh I cover my butt
pad and it's just like a padded bra but
it's for your for a buttons okay yeah I
understand that but is this something
that everybody's doing now am I the only
one that doesn't know about this I had
no idea
does anyone else know about it yeah you
can and if you have if you suffer from
which I know you do flapjack buns
you could be wearing a buff also known
as washboard ass so I could get one of
those I have is a problem for me there's
nothing there it's a straight drop and
would you feel better would you feel
more confident by having one in you know
what I never thought that men were
supposed to have didn't I didn't think
it mattered for man like supposed to
from your vocabulary
men are men or women are not supposed to
do anything it's how you feel good yeah
I like buns yeah I think I mentioned it
before right I'd like to have an ass
okay I'll get butt pads and then there
are other tricks that we don't know
about crazy things that women go through
yeah that night there's this tape call I
was wearing like a really deep v-neck
and there's this tape called Luca flex
and I just I taped my nipple to my
shoulder I just went oh wait so your
nipples touching your shoulder
oh they're sort of a trap I see for a
minute I thought it was like well you
know you got it just gonna look like
you're carrying something or I'm
covering it I got it so that's to make
them stay and then also be up so that
you're like not you know here like
you're wearing a bra but I couldn't wear
a bra and I just did the tape my stylist
Nicole Jabez is like genius and she's
done I mean she does so much stuff
underneath the clothes it's crazy but
then I posted about those because I
think we mentioned oh yes no you address
of the DV tape your movies out okay but
what do you want for this just feel good
about it if you don't want you don't do
it you know what I mean what happens at
the end of the night when it's like rip
rip you know that's what I'm thinking
about that's why it's specific tape it
doesn't hurt oh it doesn't hurt I mean
it doesn't feel awesome but it doesn't
like it doesn't hurt like a piece of
duct tape yeah you know see guys I think
it's a lot of guys we don't we just
whatever that's you know that's also
fine but yeah guys get nervous to like
put energy into their look and that and
if you don't want to don't do it but
some guys like it and go for it okay
that's I'm gonna take my nipples tonight
you